und diese eisen golem sollen laut
minecraft wiki an die roboter aus dem
film das schloss im himmel erinnert info
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft hatte am dienstag ich bin aus
dem urlaub zurück ich habe jetzt schon
anderthalb wochen keine videos mehr
gemacht und irgendwie glaube ich dass
ich alles verlernt habe also wenn ihr
das video seht kann ich zumindest noch
ein bisschen was youtube angeht aber ich
würde da irgendwo noch eine ganz große
sache und zwar zuerst ein neuer pc da
allerdings nämlich das video gerade noch
mit meinem alten pc von die nächsten
vier wahrscheinlich auch wenn erstmal
alles einrichten muss die zweite sache
ist ich habe wieder meinen alten skin
hier am start weil er nicht mehr
weihnachten nicht mehr weihnachtszeit
ist sondern es ist ja jetzt schon
weihnachten vorbei mehr oder weniger und
die dritte sagen ich befinde mich nicht
mehr in der damaligen christmas packs
welt sondern
also ich bin nicht mehr in dieser
normale
ich bin nicht mehr in der christmas welt
weil halt wirklich wie gesagt
weihnachten ist vorbei und ich befinde
mich wieder in ganz normalen text welten
wenn ihr bock habt mir gefällts machen
könnte davon einfach ein youtube video
hochladen mit den link irgendwie
zukommen lassen irgendwie eine
kommentare schreiben oder irgendwie was
machen oder ich nehme irgendeine welt
aus microsoft forum und dann habe ich
endlich mal so eine welt die ich quasi
dann immer für die facts folge nehme
also eine richtige arena oder irgendwie
sowas aber die sache ist halt bei vielen
facts sprenge ich immer viel effekt
springe ich einfach immer die welten und
es ist nicht so cool wenn ich immer
meine arena in die luft jagen wir fangen
ich befinde mich in einer anderen welt
das habe ich aber extra so gemacht weil
mir der erste effekt zu gesendet wurde
von 240 4 hd ich habe herausgefunden
dass werden üblicherweise nach einiger
zeit die normale minecraft musik
abgespielt wird sie einfach besser wird
wenn man in den gamer wechselt deswegen
habe ich eine neue welt gemacht weil in
der neuen welt ist es immer so von
anfang an in den ersten zehn sekunden
fängt die musik an zu spielen wenn immer
genau hinhört ihr hört die musik schon
jedenfalls wenn ich jetzt in den game
mode 1 wechsele ich mache jetzt mal eben
den ton lauter wenn ich jetzt enter
gleich drücke dann seht ihr die musik
hört abrupt auf ich weiß nicht was
dieser game.de viel damit zu tun hat
aber hört einfach mal selbst hin
ich weiß nicht woran das liegt und kann
mir das selber auch nicht erklären ich
habe hier nichts verändert in den
einstellungen ihr habt ja gesehen musik
ist an gesamt lautstärke sein aber das
ist nur eins und der zieht ist cool also
ich bin genau hier gespannt und wenn ihr
den zitaten leben freude aber das war
feck nummer eins jetzt kompakter zahlen
wie bei jedem und wieder einmal eine
coole andere nicht mal waren sehr
welligen wie sie hier viel cooler gerade
und zwar wurde mit dieser fake
zugesendet von feilitzsch philipp
philipp ich glaube ich habe das richtig
ausgesprochen irgendwie und zwar
schreibt er das ganze habe ich in einer
minecraft hacks folge 72 gesehen wenn
man einen sand durch einen spinnenweben
gliedern lässt darunter ein tnt zone
bleibt der sand kann zum beispiel die
spinnenweben gehen kaputt so das heißt
ich werde jetzt einfach mal hier das tmt
anzünden und jetzt zerstöre ich hier den
links und ihr seht schon das feld da
zeitgleich durch und alles fliegt in die
luft
außer der sand blog zeigt nochmal ebene
setzt erst 1 tmg hin dann zwei
spinnennetz sondern darauf noch einen
sand blog jetzt mache ich mal einfach so
der sand fällt dadurch und ihr seht
schon alles fliegt in die luft aus
der sand blog.de das so ist vielleicht
weil es am block gerade einer bewegung
ist und deswegen nicht als block
angesehen wird
allerdings kann ich mir das dann auch
nicht richtig erklären und zwar wenn ich
das mal ganz einfach so machen zwar ich
setze jetzt hier beispielsweise mal den
sand blog einfach hin
so setzt jetzt hier einen tnt hin zu
ende das an und lasst den sand lockt
jetzt die durchfallen dann seht ihr
allerdings wenn ihr das tnt explodiert
dass der sand blog auch hier bleibt also
ich habe keine ahnung woran das liegt
doch das netz nur in der bewegung liegt
oder irgendwas anderem oder so dass der
block da nicht als richtiger blog
anerkannt wird ich weiß es nicht
jedenfalls könnt ihr damit einen blog
retten und ja das war feck nummer 29 ich
freue mich also die neuen videos mit
einem neuen pc aufzunehmen also viele
wissen es ja schon durch instagram ich
habe mir einen einbeck gekauft einen
imac 5k weil ich den hauptsächlich apple
mäßig nutze für die uni und so weiter
und so fort aber der hat auch ich habe
jetzt mal aufrecht einmal mit bootcamps
ein bisschen mein windows drauf gepackt
gegen die 200 mb 200 gigabyte oder so
und minecraft hatte ich da glaube ich
simon fps unter fünf katzen zocken ist
so geil also das ist richtig stark
aber naja das ist ein anderes thema den
mit dem werde ich dann die nächsten
videos irgendwann dann die nächsten tage
oder so aufnehmen wir kommen aber
erstmals opec nummer 3 der mit
zugewinnen von jakob wurde zu gesendet
wurde von jacobs richtig wenn du ein
ender perle durch ein netter portal wird
dann verschwindet diese und kommt
nirgends so an ihr kennt ja ganz normale
werte nennt abt ehrlich bin extra für
den gamer null gegangen
damit ich hier auch ein appell werfen
kann bei dem game und 1 kann man das ja
nicht allerdings wenn ihr seht ich wäre
für die ender perle durch das portal und
die kommt nicht im netz also ich wenn
ich ihm dann uns würde ich jetzt quasi
in den neckar teleportiert werden die
kennt es ja wenn ich ein item hier der
einspeise so dann kommt es in den netto
aber diese hier kommt nicht in netter
weil sonst würde ich ein netter
teleportiert werden und die fällt auch
nicht auf der rückseite wieder rauf also
wenn ich jetzt mal hier schau ich weiß
nicht wie ich euch das mal zeigen kann
so ich werde hier durch ihr seht da oben
fliegt nicht langweilig allerdings so
werfe dann wurde ich gerade teleportiert
wenn ich mich fort portal werbetätigkeit
teleportiert aber wenn ich durch das
portal durch das passiert einfach nichts
um die vierte effekt wurde mir
zugesendet von johnny und zwar befinde
ich mich gerade schon in dem netten und
ihr kennt es ja wenn ich immer bin und
im wasser einmal hinsetzen nicht weil
das hier zu heiss ist für das wasser das
wasser direkt verdunstet soll das hohen
etwa darstellen
wenn ich jetzt allerdings so arm dran
wenn das sich im game unten 0 bin und
irgendwie ins wird in lava gier in die
lava gehe dann fange ich an zu brennen
dann kann ich mich retten indem ich
scheiße ich hab nicht getroffen ok keine
panik ich bin wieder an der stelle also
merkt euch ich bin im game mode 0 und
ich sehe hier diese lava und denke so
unfall da rein und brennen und ich kann
es eh kein wasser setzen und bin kurz
vorm sterben aber ich kann an einen
kessel gehen und ihr seht schon aus dem
kessel ist ein bisschen was heraus
gegangen
das heißt ich wurde dadurch quasi
gelöscht das heißt wenn ihr netter geht
einfach kessel mit modischen ich gehe in
lava und ich brenne ich gehe einfach
kurz im kessel dem kessel in kette
tigkeiten das ist sehr schwer zu treffen
aber ich war drin und ihr seht schon das
wasser ist wieder weniger geworden
rennen nicht mehr und alles ist schillig
also das ist eigentlich ganz gute taktik
und zwar einfach ein wasser einmal
mitnehmen und einen kessel in den neckar
und wenn ich schnell und geschickt seien
bisher nicht so tollpatschig wie ich
dann könnt ihr euch damit löschen wenn
ihr brennt und das ist extrem cool
nächste sache ist wieder eine
einblendung und zwar wurde es mir
zugesendet von dem minecraft wikipedia
effekt aus mai kräftig genommen ich
mutter darauf nur aufmerksam von einem
effekt er mir von einem user zuge seiner
wurde der aber falsch war der aber auch
von dem thema handelte und dann habe ich
einfach mal richtig informiert und ich
habe gesehen dass in minecraft wiki
steht aufgrund ihres aussehens und der
tatsache dass die manchmal rosen in der
hand tragen liegt die vermutung nahe
dass sie an die roboter aus dem film das
schloss im himmel erinnern sollen also
ich rede von eisen kohle sind ja gerade
so ein bild und das habt ihr eventuell
schon mal wirklich in minecraft gesehen
ich zumindest hat es eigentlich noch nie
gesehen aber wenn es da steht muss es ja
stimmen und es ist auch so wenn man
eisen golems tötet bekommt man immer
zwischen drei und fünf eisen und eine
rose bzw mohn heiß ist ja mittlerweile
und das kann auch sein dass eisen golems
teilweise diese rose in der hand tragen
und die dorfbewohner schenk mal eisen
golems wisst ihr sind die beschützer der
dorfbewohner und sehen auch von dem
aussehen her so ein bisschen so aus und
diese eisen golems sollen laut minecraft
wiki an die roboter aus dem film das
schloss im himmel erinnern weil da es
auch so ein roboter und er gibt diesen
kleinen japanischen oder chinesischen
leuten so blümchen so hosen und das ist
eigentlich mega cool und der film
eigentlich auch voll cool also ich hab
den geguckt als ich fünf war glaube ich
muss ich älter gewesen seien ich glaube
dabei schon zehn oder zwölf oder so auf
jeden fall dass der film extrem coole
sind so leute und die gehen dann auf
seinen schloss das ist im himmel und in
dem schlossen extrem viele schätze und
damit kann man quasi die weltherrschaft
an sicherheits nicht kann schlägt so
dinge zusammenfassen die ich vor so
langer zeit gesehen aber google einfach
mal schloss im himmel und daran sollen
wohl diesen golems erinnern und das
perfekt nummer fünf danke an dich
minecraft wiki mein sinn
wieso winke ich hallo micro wickie hey
hallo freunde damit würde ich sagen war
es das dann auch schon für diese folge
der minecraft wenn es euch gefallen dann
will ich mich über eine bewertung freuen
wenn ihr jetzt noch dran seid dann
schreib doch mal in die kommentare
kuqi weil
ich mag cookie sondern sich das ihr bis
zwei tagen geblieben war wird seit blatt
wird mich auf jeden fall freuen wenn ihr
am freitag wieder in die nächste folge
minecraft einschaltet und dann würdigt
dem wir uns da wieder